pero sin duda alguna lo que nosotros
podemos observar hasta el momento es que
el ciudadano estadounidense es el
ganador de esta contienda es increíble
ver como los resultados parciales por
ejemplo en el estado de la florida ya
reflejan que se sobrepasó el total de
votos que hubo hace cuatro años y
realmente las estrategias de campaña
pueden observar que claramente ha sido
un estado significativamente reñido si
nosotros nos desplazamos a otros lugares
vamos a observar una particularidad
siendo las 9 de la noche en la costa
este de los eeuu
observamos que el presidente de trump en
cada uno de los estados pendulares le
está dando una importante batalla a un
elemento que considerábamos y va a
favorecer a los demócratas
y es que ese masivo voto anticipado o
ese masivo voto ausente iba a favorecer
a los demócratas y no necesariamente los
resultados parciales no se están
reflejando eso es decir hay una ventana
de oportunidad para que la noche sea más
larga de lo que nosotros pensamos en un
momento inicial porque porque no se
decantan con claridad los estados que se
vienen anunciando es cierto que carolina
del norte
punteando el candidato joe biden
especialmente en la zona que conocemos
como triángulo que es donde se encuentra
la universidad de carolina del norte
chapel hill sin duda alguna ahí van a
ganar los demócratas y eventualmente lo
harán en el en la parte norte este donde
se encuentra una importante población
afro pero en otros lugares el presidente
viene despuntando muy bien en ese estado
al final de la noche vamos a saber con
preocupación con preocupación para los
demócratas en el estado de michigan que
hasta ahora ha reportado el 5 por ciento
en la zona de detroit va ganando el
candidato joe biden pero en los
suburbios y eso lo dijimos desde el
inicio esos condados van a ser
fundamentales
oakland y marko van a ser indispensables
si yo badén quiere ganar ahorita en
pocos minutos vamos a ver cómo se van a
cerrar las urnas en minnesota y se van a
cerrar las urnas en wisconsin dos
estados claves para seguir asegurando
una posible ola azul en dado caso de que
sigan los resultados de la forma en la
que eventualmente se podrían dar en eso
del norte hay que esperar qué pasa con
pensilvania cuyos resultados también son
particularmente en contradictorio si se
quiere tradicionalmente vota muy fuerte
en filadelfia y vota muy fuerte
alrededor del partido demócrata en la
zona de pittsburgh pero vemos que la
zona de pittsburgh el presidente de
donald trump lo viene haciendo bastante
bien